when you're sitting in the hospital one
of the first things doctors evaluate is
your biggest organ skin here are 14 ways
your skin actually tells me a lot about
your health just remember changes to
your skin may be a benign variant and
there are always multiple diagnoses to
consider that's why I included a list of
potential other options called a
differential right here on this
clipboard if you're ever concerned or
spot a new change though don't hesitate
to seek professional medical advice
if your skin has lots of bruising that
happens really easily your blood may be
having a problem with clotting that's
because one of the most prominent signs
of a condition known as hemophilia is
easy breathability due to the fact that
bleeding becomes harder to control
[Music]
if your skin has a cut that refuses to
heal for a long time you may have skin
cancer I'm not exaggerating here a
non-healing wound on the face to me is
skin cancer unless proven otherwise this
is because the face heals so much faster
than other parts of the body and it's
one of the most that's exposed to the
Sun
[Music]
if your skin has hair growth in unusual
places as a woman you may have PCOS
females having hair suddenly appear in
areas like the upper lip chest and back
can be a sign of excess testosterone
often occurring with polycystic ovarian
syndrome this is because androgenic
hormones like testosterone can cause
Peach fuss or vellus hair to develop
into larger darker terminal hair
[Music]
if your skin has a bullseye shaped rash
you might have been hiking recently
especially in the northeast of the U.S
that's because one of the most common
but not all the time early presentations
of Lyme disease comes with the erythema
migrants rash Lyme disease is spread by
these guys deer ticks so be sure to
follow tips on how to best protect
yourself
if you have a red rash across your nose
and face with light sensitivity you
might have increased inflammation
throughout your whole body from lupus
that's because immune related changes in
the skin causes to become extra
sensitive and overreact to UV exposure
from the Sun so the most Sun exposed
regions like your nasal bridge and
cheeks get affected the most and it's
important to remember that lupus affects
more than just your skin
if you have darkening of the folds of
your skin in the neck armpit or groin
you may have diabetes acanthosis Niger
Kansas when a hormonal disturbance
usually insulin related causes an uptick
of certain cells in the skin changing
its appearance to become more thickened
velvety and dark early onset of this
should trigger a discussion with your
doctor about certain blood tests
if you have more than 50 moles on your
skin you could have a higher risk of a
type of skin cancer known as melanoma
moles also known as beauty marks are
brown pigmented spots that are a result
of cells called melanocytes tightly
gathering together into clusters most of
them are quite harmless and are very
common it's not that moles lead to
cancer but instead a correlation that we
have found to be true and we could use
this correlation to help guide risk
stratification and prevention
if I squeeze your nail and the blanching
or whitening does not resolve within two
to three seconds you could be going into
shock this is called the capillary
refill test by squeezing the tip of the
finger we're able to temporarily cut off
blood supply and upon release we expect
to see reperfusion of color from blood
very quickly if this process takes
longer than three seconds there's an
issue with circulation why the nail bed
well it's less impacted by melanin and
therefore there's less variation across
humans
[Music]
if your skin is very pale on your
conjunctiva or Palms you may have a fast
heart rate because you're anemic on
areas where there's less variation from
person to person we're able to see a
decrease in that red Hue symbolizing
that perhaps there's less oxygen
carrying ability in the blood vessels
this could be due to a problem with the
red blood cells or perfusion issue like
hypertension or blockages when your
tissues aren't getting enough oxygen
your heart tries to compensate for this
by beating faster
[Music]
if your skin has a defined area of
redness and scaling over your neckline
or earlobes you might be wearing
inexpensive jewelry contact dermatite is
one of the most common skin conditions
we see in Primary Care the interesting
part about the diagnosis is that the
condition is usually very localized to
where the contact had occurred so the
red patches have very unique shapes
outlining the exact shape of that
allergic cause nickel is actually one of
the more common Metals causing this
immune overreaction on the skin and it's
commonly found in costume jewelry and
belt buckles
if your skin has yellow growths on or
near the eyelids you may be consuming
too many fatty animal products AKA high
cholesterol xanthelasma is a benign Mass
where cholesterol deposits build up onto
the skin while the growth itself is not
usually problematic it can represent a
disorder of the management of fats and
cholesterols in your body leading to
other conditions like heart disease
that's why in addition to addressing
cosmetic concerns with these lesions we
also routinely check blood lipid and
other tests
[Music]
if your skin has one of these spider
angiomas on your face neck or upper
chest you may have a liver problem like
cirrhosis interestingly enough these
unique blood vessels occur in pregnancy
as well as with liver disorders the
exact mechanism for why and how they're
formed is not even fully understood but
the hormone estrogen in certain vascular
growth factors have been implicated in
initial research
if your skin doesn't bounce back after
being pinched you may need some water
this is called The Skin turgor test and
basically checks your Skin's resiliency
after being manipulated if you are
heavily heavily dehydrated then skin
struggles to return to its normal
position quickly however there's an
important caveat here that this test
needs to be thought about in context as
someone over the age of 65 may have
naturally less resilient skin simply due
to age not dehydration
if your skin is yellow you might be
drinking too much alcohol jaundice is a
well-known condition for causing this
unique change the color change actually
stems from bilirubin which is a yellow
orange breakdown product of red blood
cells it is normally processed by the
liver to be passed into the digestive
system as bile then it's excreted
through urine and stool however if
there's damage to the liver from alcohol
the bilirubin can enter your bloodstream
and therefore cause yellow skin
discoloration so many people ask me if
sparkling water is good for their health
will I answer that question and more on
this responding to comments video click
here to check that out and as always
stay happy and healthy